.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich war auf der Toilette
und beim Urinieren war noch nichts.
Ich putzte ab, stand auf und merkte,
dass es doch langsam anfing.
Jetzt fliesst es langsam.
Mein Energielevel ist down.
Jetzt hat gerade
so richtiges Bauchweh angefangen.
Ich überlege,
ob ich eine Tablette nehmen soll.
Es ist jetzt nach dem Eisprung.
Seit Jahren
plagt mich dann immer Akne.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Es gibt in diesem Film ja Frauen,
die ihr Menstruationsblut zeigen.
Mhm.
Ich finde es super,
dass sie das machen.
Ich finde das mega gut.
Das ist auch mega wichtig.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass gewisse Männer noch nie
Menstruationsblut gesehen haben.
Aber ich habe es nicht geschafft.
Ich konnte das nicht filmen.
Warum?
Weil es auch sehr persönlich ist.
Das ist wie ...
Es ist ziemlich intim.
Warum haben Sie sich entschieden,
das zu zeigen?
Weil es wichtig ist, zu zeigen,
dass es so natürlich
wie Ein- und Ausatmen ist.
Ich finde es nach wie vor crazy,
dass die Menschen immer noch
Probleme mit ihren Säften haben.
Das ist so natürlich wie ...
... ja, die Natur. Es ist Natur.
Ich bin Bea Loosli. Ich bin 42.
Die Mens fasziniert mich privat
und beruflich.
Ich habe seit über elf Jahren
einen Onlineshop
und ein Onlineportal für Frauen.
Dort geht es um das Thema
Frausein und Menstruieren
und natürlich um Verhütung.
Jeden Monat baut sich der Nährboden
in unserer Gebärmutter neu auf,
falls wir
neues Leben empfangen wollen,
das sich dort einnisten könnte.
Es ist genau dasselbe
wie bei diesem Blümchen.
Das ist eine Schleimhaut.
Die allererste Mens, die ihr in
eurem Leben habt, ist die Menarche.
Das ist immer das grosse Thema:
"Huch, jetzt sind wir fruchtbar."
Und:
"Huch, unser Teenie ist verliebt."
Man kann
eins und eins zusammenzählen
und spätestens dann
ist es an der Zeit,
mit der jungen Lady und dem jungen
Herren über Verhütung zu sprechen.
Ich weiss nicht mehr, ob es in der
fünften oder sechsten Klasse war.
Ich weiss nur,
dass ich weisse Hosen anhatte
und im Singunterricht am Boden war.
Dann macht ein Junge:
Ich schaute runter und: "Boah!"
Da stand ich auf, ging zur Lehrerin
und sagte, ich müsse nach Hause.
Sie fragte, ob mir übel sei.
Ich machte so und sie sagte:
"Oh, geh!"
Ich rannte nach Hause.
Ich war mega aufgeregt.
Freude hatte ich nicht, nein.
Dadurch, dass man vorher
gar nicht aufgeklärt wurde ...
... was das soll ...
Wieso sollte man sich freuen?
Ja.
Es gibt ein paar, die eine Party
machten, als sie ihre Tage kriegten.
Ich z.B. nicht. Das kackte mich an.
Ich fand wirklich:
"Ah, jetzt habe ich das."
Aber ja, schlussendlich
bin ich einfach damit umgegangen,
wie man das halt macht.
Aber eigentlich dachte ich:
"Wieso wird die Frau bestraft?"
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Ich bin Melanie Brugger.
Ich bin in Bangladesch geboren.
Ich wurde von Schweizer Eltern
adoptiert.
Ich bin Mutter von zwei Kindern.
Mein Beruf ist Störköchin
und Catering.
Um den Eisprung ist es sehr kritisch
mit meinem Mann.
Wir müssen stark darauf achten, dass
wir keine krassen Streite haben.
Es sitzt mir dann
wie ein Teufel im Nacken ...
... der mich wie fernsteuert.
Ich bin z.T. auch wie ...
... etwas boshaft -
und das will ich gar nicht.
Heute filme ich mich in der Küche.
Hier stehe ich ...
... am meisten.
Das wird ein Boeuf Stroganoff
mit einem Vanille-Risotto.
Hier dünsten die Zwiebeln.
Das Rindfleisch
habe ich schon vorgeschmort.
Weil ich heute
so Rückenschmerzen habe,
habe ich so einen Hüftgürtel ...
... der mir Halt gibt, sonst könnte
ich vor Schmerzen kaum stehen.
Jetzt muss ich wieder mal rühren.
Das erschwert mir meinen Job
natürlich jeweils ziemlich.
Ich wäre am liebsten
ab dem Eisprung zwei Wochen alleine.
Ich halte dann nichts
und niemanden aus.
Ich bräuchte dann viel Ruhe,
die ich natürlich nie habe.
(Jo) Das hier ist ein Wärmekissen
in Form eines Pandabären.
Das ist mein treuster Begleiter
für meine ...
... Bauchkrämpfe ...
... während der Mens.
Ich leide extrem und habe sehr
starke Bauch- und Rückenschmerzen.
Das zieht bis in die Beine.
(Bea) Das A und O
gegen Mensschmerzen ist alles,
was Bewegung ins Becken bringt.
Ein bisschen Hula Hoop ...
Vibration hilft auch. Ihr könnt
euren Vibi auch ausserhalb nutzen.
Und ...
... viele hören das nicht gerne,
aber: Sex wäre super dagegen.
Damit sich der Krampf
durch die Vibration des Sex löst.
Ich stehe wieder mal
vor dem Dilemma,
wie so oft -
auch wenn sie noch nicht da ist ...
Ich habe so Bauchschmerzen
und überlege,
ein Schmerzmedikament zu nehmen.
Eigentlich
möchte ich nicht zu viele schlucken.
Aber wenn ich es zu spät nehme,
werden die Schmerzen so extrem ...
... dass ich nicht weiss,
wie ich morgen arbeiten soll.
Ich bin sehr pflichtbewusst.
Ich versuche, bei der Arbeit nicht
zu fehlen, weil man das so macht.
Auch gerade
mit Menstruationsschmerzen, oder?
Ja, allgemein, aber gerade
beim Menstruationsschmerz.
Das haben alle Frauen jeden Monat.
Warum soll ich dann nicht arbeiten,
wenn alle anderen das auch machen?
Alle anderen gehen auch zur Arbeit.
Als ich erwachte,
nahm ich CBD-Kügelchen.
Dann stand ich auf ...
... und nahm ein Ibuprofen.
Danach machte ich eine Bettflasche
und ging ins Bett zurück
und wartete, bis es wirkte.
Das Ganze hat noch nichts
oder nicht genug gewirkt,
weshalb ich noch ein Dafalgan nahm.
So sollte ich jetzt dann ...
... um 9 Uhr
zur Arbeit gehen können.
Genau.
Das nehme ich alles
auch mit zur Arbeit,
damit ich es dabeihabe und am Mittag
oder in der Pause brauchen kann.
Bis jetzt habe ich nur ...
... Dinge abgesagt,
die mit einem Hobby zu tun haben.
Sonst habe ich noch nie
etwas abgesagt wegen meiner Mens.
Ich nahm dann einfach Tabletten.
Es gibt einen Satz
in der feministischen Bewegung:
"All you do I can do bleeding."
Also: "Alles, was du schaffst,
schaffe ich während ich blute."
Ich fand das lange cool.
Und jetzt bin ich nicht mehr sicher,
ob ich das cool finde.
Natürlich ist das toll.
Wenn ich etwas machen muss und ich
habe meine Tage, ist das halt so -
das ist keine Ausrede. Wir lächeln
darüber und ziehen es durch.
Aber eigentlich
wäre es auch total okay zu sagen:
"Heute geht es mir nicht so gut."
"Ich mag das nicht machen."
Aber davon
sind wir meilenweit entfernt.
Das würde ich mich
auch nicht trauen,
obwohl es eigentlich okay wäre.
Ich konnte mich bei der Arbeit
nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Ich ging etwas früher nach Hause
und liess die Arbeit liegen.
Ich habe auch noch mal ein stärkeres
Schmerzmittel, Novalgin, genommen.
Ich muss etwas liegen und hoffe,
dass es schnell wirkt.
Eine Bettflasche mache ich mir dann
auch noch und massiere meinen Bauch.
Vielleicht kann ich dann was essen.
Jetzt bin ich nicht hungrig.
* Gong *
Ich bin Nadia.
Ich werde bald 30.
Ich bin Ergotherapeutin
und arbeite in einer Praxis,
v.a. mit Menschen
mit psychischen Erkrankungen.
Ich mag Klänge
und achtsame, ruhige Momente.
* Der Ton klingt langsam aus. *
Ich wusste
bis vor einem Jahr nicht ...
... dass es Frauen gibt,
die ihre Mens nicht spüren,
abgesehen davon, dass sie bluten.
Das ist für mich unvorstellbar.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Und ich bin bald 30.
Wir reden also zu wenig darüber.
- Ja, viel zu wenig.
Es ist schwierig,
über das Thema zu sprechen.
Es braucht etwas Überwindung.
Es ist wie in den Frauen verankert:
"Wenn ich meine Tage habe,
bin ich nur noch halbwertig."
Darum die blöden Sprüche:
"Hast du deine Tage?"
Das hat alles damit zu tun.
Man spielt das runter:
"Ja, die hat halt ihre Tage."
Damit ist es abgestempelt.
Ich weiss wirklich nicht,
warum das so ein Tabu ist.
Niemand soll herausfinden,
dass man gerade seine Tage hat.
Aber ich weiss es nicht.
Ich glaube, daran kann
die ganze Gesellschaft arbeiten.
Man braucht dann halt einen Tampon.
Die Männer dürfen das
genauso mitkriegen wie die Frauen.
Männer wollen ja auch Kinder
und können froh sein,
wenn Frauen bluten,
sonst kriegt man keine Kinder.
(Bea) Ja, so sieht das halt aus.
Ein echter Blutfleck.
Alle, die sagen,
sie fänden das eklig:
Wenn man einen o.b. rausnimmt,
sieht man mehr Blut.
Ich bringe einen Tisch
mit 20 Frauen ...
... nicht 15-, 16-jährigen -
zum Schweigen wenn ich sage,
was ich verkaufe.
Warum?
- Es ist ihnen peinlich.
Ich bin Petra Häfeli-Kaiser.
Ich bin Mutter von zwei Mädchen.
Ich habe mein eigenes Business
auf die Beine gestellt
und verkaufe Periodenunterwäsche.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Das ist ein Slip,
den die Frau anziehen kann,
wenn sie ihre Erdbeertage
oder Periode hat.
Sie braucht keinen Cup,
keinen o.b., keine Binde - nichts.
Man kann es einfach fliessen lassen.
Das bin ich als Model.
Ja, ich habe keinen Model-Körper.
Ja.
Schämten Sie sich nicht,
sich so zu zeigen?
Es brauchte schon etwas Überwindung.
Das brauchte es wirklich.
Aber ich fand dann: "Ich
verkaufe das und kann dazu stehen."
"Ja, wir machen das."
Dann fand mein Mann:
"Das stellen wir auf Facebook."
Es kamen dann
auch viele blöde Kommentare:
"Wäh, eklig!" und so.
Aber ...
- Das waren die Kommentare?
Ja. "Blut ist doch eklig."
"Wenn du es auswaschen musst,
hast du es an den Händen."
Als würde man einen o.b.
nur mit Handschuhen anfassen.
Das hat wohl mit früher zu tun.
Ich denke ... Ja ...
Wenn die Frau ihre Periode hatte,
wurde sie von Anfang an
wie eine Aussätzige behandelt.
Man sagte ja nicht,
sie habe ihre Periode.
Man sagte, sie habe den bösen Blick.
D.h. eigentlich, dass sie dann
nichts in die Hände nehmen durfte.
Z.B. durfte sie nicht melken,
weil die Milch sonst sauer würde.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Ich bin Jo Vergeat, bin Kantonsrätin
im Kanton Basel-Stadt
für das junge grüne Bündnis.
Ich studiere Geografie
und Soziologie
und setze mich für Frauenthemen ein.
Das eine ist ja die Blutung,
die niemand thematisiert.
Das andere ist aber alles,
was damit kommt:
die Schmerzen,
die Stimmungsschwankungen
und all diese Einflüsse.
Die werden einfach totgeschwiegen.
Das ist so eine Instagram-Story.
Ich kommentiere quasi immer
meine Tage.
Hier hat alles angefangen.
Das ist eine Toilette
in einem Verwaltungsgebäude
des Kantons Basel-Stadt.
Ich habe hier eine Sitzung geleitet
und kriegte während dieser Sitzung
meine Tage.
Ich machte dann einen Post
aus diesem Badezimmer hier.
Ich schrieb,
dass ich mich gefreut hätte,
wenn es auf dem WC gratis
ein paar Hygieneartikel gäbe.
Daraufhin
gab es einen riesigen Aufruhr.
Das gehöre nicht
in die Öffentlichkeit,
das sei ein ekliges Thema, darüber
würden Frauen nicht sprechen.
Ja, das traf mich.
Das nahm mich richtig mit.
Was denn?
Die Vorwürfe,
die damit verbunden waren:
dass ich nicht ehrenvoll sei,
dass ich nicht ernst zu nehmen sei
in meiner Arbeit,
dass das meine
politischen Fähigkeiten abwerte ...
... dass ich dumm sei und blöd,
weil ich nicht mitdenken könne.
Das ist einfach verletzend.
Wieso thematisieren Sie das
immer wieder?
Weil es mich nervt,
dass es immer noch so ist.
Wir sind eigentlich
so weit gekommen
und gleichzeitig
sind wir das einfach nicht,
weil es eben die Hälfte der Leute
in der Schweiz betrifft.
Es gibt
viele menstruierende Menschen,
die sich einmal pro Monat
oder auch den ganzen Monat
damit beschäftigen müssen.
Man hat nicht die Wahl, sich
für Bauchschmerzen zu entscheiden.
Es passiert einfach.
Wenn wir nie darüber sprechen
und es immer
unter den Teppich gekehrt wird,
verändert sich nichts für die Frauen
und die Leute,
die mit der Menstruation
und dem Zyklus leben.
Heute ist Reisetag.
Spannenderweise
fällt der mehr oder weniger
genau auf den Beginn meiner Periode.
Das ist sowieso
eine etwas unangenehme Zeit.
Ich verhüte nicht mit der Pille,
habe also keinen getakteten Zyklus.
Es könnte jetzt losgehen,
aber auch nicht.
Ich habe Material dabei, aber ...
... ich finde das immer
eine etwas unangenehme Stimmung,
um die Zeit herum.
Jetzt gehen wir in den Bus
und ich hoffe,
ich muss auf kein so ekliges Zug-WC.
Ihr kennt das alle, liebe Frauen:
in einem Hotelzimmer
oder wie ich gerade bei Freunden ...
... in der Ferienwohnung
mit weisser Bettwäsche.
Ich habe meine Menstasse drin.
Das ist etwas vom Schlimmsten,
wenn man Angst davor hat,
auswärts
die Bettwäsche zu verbluten.
Darum ziehe ich heute Abend
noch eine Mensunterhose an.
Ich bin Melanie Glover. Ich bin 26.
Ich habe an der Uni Basel
Sport-, Bewegungs- und
Gesundheitswissenschaften studiert.
Momentan
arbeite ich als Yogalehrerin,
Personal Health Coach
und als Tanzlehrerin.
Das Thema Mens interessiert mich
schon seit mehreren Jahren,
weil ich den weiblichen Zyklus
etwas mega Interessantes finde.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Ich hatte keinen regelmässigen
Zyklus, als ich die Spirale hatte.
Ich nahm sie
vor zweieinhalb Jahren raus
und brauchte dann rund ein Jahr, bis
sich das Ganze eingependelt hatte.
Mein ganzer Freundeskreis
hat die Pille abgesetzt,
die Spirale rausgenommen - es
verhüten eigentlich alle mit Kondom.
Wieso denn?
Weil die meisten
meiner Freundinnen - und ich auch -
einfach nichts Fremdes
in unserem Körper wollen.
Ich möchte meine Tage
nicht unterdrücken in dem Sinne.
Die Pille bewirkt eigentlich,
dass man die Tage unterdrückt.
Man hat z.T.
die Tage gar nicht mehr.
D.h., man muss sich nicht
mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen.
Es blutet nicht.
Das klingt alles super,
aber es ist einfach
mega unnatürlich.
Es ist etwas im Trend,
den Zyklus zu leben und zu spüren.
Wieso ist das so?
Vielleicht ist man etwas pillenmüde,
oder?
Am Anfang war das ja ein Hype.
Man fand das grossartig.
Ich fand das mit 16 super.
Es war mega bequem.
Mega angenehm für beide.
Und nach drei Jahren waren
meine Vaginalschleimhäute kaputt.
Dann fing ich an, aufzuwachen.
Wegen sieben fruchtbaren Tagen
pro Monat
müsst ihr nicht jeden Tag
Hormone nehmen.
Ich bin Bea von Ladyplanet.
Ich bin jetzt 40 und verhüte
natürlich, seit ich 21 bin.
Wenn du dich selber als Frau mal oh-
ne hormonelle Übersteuerung spürst,
gehen die Frauen in 80 % der Fälle
nicht mehr zurück.
Es ist lustig: Ich kriegte gestern
meine Tage und dachte: "Ah, ja ..."
Gleichzeitig
ist man auch erleichtert,
weil ich in meinem Alter
und meiner Situation froh bin,
nicht schwanger zu sein.
Es verbinden sich viele Gefühle
mit der Menstruation.
Ich stehe vor dem Inselspital,
vor der Frauenklinik.
Ich habe heute einen Termin,
nachdem ich vor ein paar Tagen
ein MRI hatte, um herauszufinden,
ob ich Endometriose
und deshalb solche Schmerzen habe.
Ich bin etwas nervös
und gespannt darauf, was rauskommt.
Darauf, was gesagt wird
und was das bedeutet.
Sie haben die Diagnose Endometriose
erhalten.
Wie war das für Sie?
Es war eine mega Erleichterung.
Eine Erleichterung, dass ...
... wirklich etwas ist und ich nicht
einfach ein Sensibelchen bin,
das sich doof verhält,
weil sie ihre Mens hat.
Man hat Endometriose, wenn sich die
Zellen der Gebärmutterschleimhaut
in den Bauchraum verirren.
Also, sie sind an einem Ort,
an den sie nicht hingehören.
Dann gibt es dort Verklebungen ...
... und es kann sich
weiter verteilen,
weil das mitblutet,
aber nicht abfliessen kann.
Das ist etwas, das mich nun
bis in meine Wechseljahre begleitet.
Ich kriegte meine Diagnose mit 29:
Endometriose.
Und ... ähm ...
Ich habe heute
keine Gebärmutter mehr und ...
... auch einen Teil der Eierstöcke
nicht mehr.
Einfach das, was stark befallen war.
Man entfernte auch ein grosses Stück
des Dickdarms und des Dünndarms.
Die Endometriose hatte sich dort
sehr stark verwachsen.
Ich lebe heute -
weil der Hauptherd draussen ist -
in Bezug auf die Mensbeschwerden
sicher schmerzfreier.
Wie war es vorher?
- Vorher war es die Hölle.
Ich fühle mich gerade
richtig schlecht.
Es ist der erste Tag meiner Periode.
Der zweite
ist immer am allerschlimmsten.
Morgen habe ich den ganzen Tag
Grossrat mit Nachtsitzung.
Ich bin jetzt schon
völlig erschlagen.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich
einfach gar keine Kraft und Lust.
Der ganze Körper
fühlt sich schwer an.
Ich merke, dass ich keinen Bock habe
und überhaupt nicht mag.
Heute Nachmittag
sollte ich Tennisspielen gehen.
Das ist genau das: Soll ich?
In ...
... fünf bis sechs Tagen
fängt eigentlich meine Mens an.
Ich bin vorher
wie in einer Depression.
Ich könnte nur noch heulen.
Ich fühle mich mega traurig.
Es ist mir alles zu viel.
Ich bin mega, mega müde.
Wir sind eigentlich
in den Skiferien.
In Arosa.
Ich kann mich dann
auch nicht wirklich freuen ...
... weil ich
so Muskelverspannungen habe.
Ich habe wirklich einfach ...
... eine Trauer in mir drin, die ...
... ja ...
... andere
in einer Depression haben.
Man denkt so: "Hey ..."
Die Lebensfreude und der Antrieb
fehlen.
Ja, oder auch ...
Die Kinder
kommen so aufgestellt nach Hause.
Das sollte einen
ja eigentlich auch direkt anstecken.
Man sollte denken:
"Wow, so cool! Das ist so süss!"
Ich bin dann so da und ...
... gebe ihnen einfach viel Liebe,
weil ich nicht mehr kann.
Ich kann die Freude und Euphorie
dann einfach nicht teilen.
Das tut mir manchmal
so weh im Herzen.
Ich würde dann doch auch gerne ...
... einfach fröhlicher sein.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Das Krasse ist, dass man ja wirklich
hormongesteuert ist.
Man kann sich nicht zusammenreissen,
wenn man ein Tief hat.
Mein Freund weiss es jetzt.
Ich sage ihm dann auch, dass ich
meine Tage habe oder sie kriege.
Dann ist das okay
und er ist sehr verständnisvoll.
Ich versuche, mich zu bemühen.
Ein Stück weit kann man ja
versuchen, nicht alle anzuschnauzen.
Aber ich merke schon,
dass ich in der PMS-Phase -
also fünf Tage vor meinen Tagen,
bis hin zu meinen Tagen -
sehr, sehr sensibel bin.
Ich werde sehr schnell wütend
und bin sehr schnell beleidigt.
Also, ich merke das bei mir extrem.
Irgendwann einmal fiel mir ...
... der Wäscheständer um.
Normalerweise fange ich nicht an,
deswegen zu weinen.
Aber ich fing einfach an zu weinen.
Ich habe mich dann
schon wieder beruhigt,
aber teilweise ist es einfach
ein Stimmungstief vor der Mens.
Und das Krasse ist:
Wenn das wirklich ganz intensiv ist,
ist es echt so, dass es weg ist,
sobald es anfängt zu bluten.
Von einem Moment auf den nächsten
geht es mir psychisch
bzw. stimmungsmässig wieder gut.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
(Bea)
Tampons gehören ja nicht ins WC.
Der kommt schön in den Kübel.
Obwohl ...
... ich extra mal
in der Kläranlage nachgefragt habe:
Tampons können sie gut rausrechen.
Das Schlimmste für die Kläranlagen
sind die oft genutzten Feuchttücher.
Das ist jetzt eben das eingepackte
Bindenzeugs von einer Nacht.
Ein riesiges Ding.
Abfallmässig ist das einfach crazy.
Weltweit.
Das muss einfach nicht sein.
Nur schon ein benutzter Tampon und
eine Binde ergeben diesen Abfall.
Mit der Menstasse oder dem -schwamm
hat man keinen Abfall.
Das geniesse ich
seit zwölf Jahren mega.
Mega megamässig.
Weil es wirklich
anfängt zu fliessen ...
... nehme ich die Menstasse,
weil ich nachher noch Tennis spiele.
Das ist überhaupt nicht neu,
das gibt es seit 1937.
Wir kennen das in der Schweiz
fast nicht.
Ich kenne das seit zwölf Jahren
und bin begeistert.
Es gibt ungefähr 40 bis 60
verschiedene Tassenmarken.
Den LadyCup faltet ihr zweimal
und führt ihn wie einen Tampon ein.
Dann noch einmal fast ganz raus,
damit es schön ploppt.
Nach zwei bis sechs Stunden,
je nach Frau,
leert ihr ihn.
Ihr müsst den Stiel ergreifen,
das Vakuum lösen und entleeren.
Ich hätte nie
eine Menstruationstasse gebraucht,
wenn ich nicht jemanden
gesehen hätte, der das braucht.
Es war keine Freundin,
die mir sagte, ich solle die nehmen.
Es war irgendeine Bloggerin
aus den USA oder so.
Ich glaube, es ist sogar so,
dass das im Zuge eines Bildes
von einem Abfallhaufen war -
auch mit Binden und so,
irgendwo an einem Strand.
Das ist natürlich etwas,
auf das ich sehr affin bin,
weil das
mein politisches Kernthema ist.
Ich dachte schon immer,
dass es doch etwas geben müsste,
damit man nicht immer nur o.b.
und Binden braucht.
Ich habe auch Cup und Schwämmchen
und alles ausprobiert, was es gibt.
Ich fand einfach nicht das Richtige.
Ich wusste,
dass es etwas geben muss.
Für Hunde gibt es etwas Ähnliches.
Halt nicht so stark
von der Saugkraft her.
Das ist unsere Hündin.
Wie man sieht,
trägt sie auch ein Höschen.
Sie hat nämlich
auch gerade ihre Tage.
Leonie, wie lange hat Lulu ihr Bobo?
* Sie brabbelt. *
Drei Wochen, ganz genau.
Lulu zieht das Höschen wieder aus.
Genau, wenn Anuk rausgeht,
kann sie das Höschen ausziehen
und drinnen muss sie es anziehen.
Nicht wahr?
Hast du drei Räder? Wo?
Wo hat es drei Räder?
Das Thema Periode ist bei uns
in der Familie absolut kein Tabu.
Ist Ihnen das auch wichtig?
- Ich finde das wichtig.
Ich finde, wir als Mütter ...
... sollten das den Mädchen erklären
und sie darauf vorbereiten.
Nicht, dass die Mädchen
bei der ersten Blutung
aus allen Wolken fallen
und Angst haben.
Und die Jungs oder die jungen Männer?
Die sollten auch wissen,
was das ist.
Weil, ja ...
Es trifft eigentlich ...
Es trifft sie indirekt,
geht sie aber auch etwas an.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Es ist eine Hassliebe
mit der Menstruation.
Irgendwo ist sie wichtig für uns
und prägt unseren Körper
und unsere Gefühle.
Aber natürlich nerve ich mich
jedes Mal, wenn ich sie kriege.
Ich sage immer, die Periode gehöre
zur Frau wie der Montag zur Woche.
Es ist nicht der Lieblingstag,
gehört aber dazu.
(Mädchen) Ich will das runterspülen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021
Soll man Periodenblut
überhaupt zeigen?
Und welche Erfahrungen habt ihr
in Bezug auf Menstruation gemacht?
Schreibt es uns in die Kommentare.
Und aktiviert am besten die Glocke,
wenn ihr nichts mehr verpassen möchtet.